Thema
Alter ist es hat es gesagt der iranische
prozessbewegung frauenorientierte
Außenpolitik ein Antrag der
Unionsfraktion erste Rednerin lamiacador
von den Bündnisgrünen
[Applaus]
ein Beispiel also da bin ich also es
geht um den Antrag der cdu/cs
Protestbewegung entschlossen
unterstützen so lautet der Antrag und
ich finde wir sehen hier ein Beispiel
für die Folgen Ideologie getriebener und
unüberlegter Wortklauberei wie der
Teufel das Weihwasser Schollen sie den
Begriff feministische Außenpolitik nicht
gelten zu lassen sprechen Sie lieber
gekünstler von frauenorientierter aus
dem Politik weiterführt leider führte
sie das genau in eine völlig falsche
Richtung das fängt schon mit dem Titel
ihres Antrags an im Text erklären Sie es
bedürfe einer konkreten Implementierung
einer echten Frauen orientierten
Außenpolitik welche die Verbesserung der
Lage der Frauen konkret in den Blick
nimmt nein es geht im Iran um sehr sehr
viel mehr die Bundesregierung und
insbesondere die bundesaußenministerin
Anna Werbung hat das sehr genau
verstanden die Proteste sind
feministisch und werden eben nicht von
Frauen für Frauen allein durchgeführt
das belegen die vielen männlichen
Demonstranten die seit nunmehr drei
Monaten auf die Straße gehen und auf
tragischste Weise Ihr Leben riskiere
denn neben der Gleichberechtigung von
Frauen geht es um nichts weniger als den
Protest gegen das Unrechtsregime der
mullers mit ihrem unrechtsapparat im
Ganzen
feministische Außenpolitik richtet sich
nicht allein von Frauen auf Frauen das
sagt ich ja bereits es geht auch um
einen emanzipatorischen und
protektionistischen Gesamtansatz im
Hinblick auf marginalisierte Gruppen
feministische Außenpolitik man zu
Einhaltung von Menschenrechten gerade
und insbesondere bei Kindern bei
Menschen mit körperlicher
Beeinträchtigung mein verfolge von Herz
aufgrund von Herkunft sexuelle
Orientierung Hautfarbe oder Religion das
haben sehr früh auch Männer im Iran
erkannt und sich solidarisch und mutig
an die Seite der DemonstrantInnen
gestellt diesen Verständnis
diesen Verständnis für feministische
Außenpolitik liegt ein großes
friedenspotenzial zugrunde dass wir die
internationale Diplomatie unablässig ist
meine Damen und Herren
mit Bestürzung haben wir alle die
barbarischen Hinrichtungen von
massenchicadi und Majid durch den Strang
genommen aufgenommen die beiden jungen
Männer hatten für einen Iran frei von
Repressionen und Unterdrückung
demonstriert und wurden dafür qualvoll
gehängt was für uns die unvorstellbar
ist ist dort seit Jahren Realität sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren statt
Reformschritte zu gehen halten die
islamistischen Machthaber an ihrer
brutalen Unterdrückungspolitik fest und
ich hoffe inständig dass die Rechnung
der Monats nicht aufgeht die mutigen
Iraner und Iraner gehen bis Datum
weiterhin auf die Straße und dazu
brauchen Sie unser aller Unterstützung
wir meinen es wir meinen es ernst mit
der feministischen Außenpolitik
gegenüber dem Iran vor allem das
Auswärtige Amt war im Duo mit Frankreich
der treibende Motor für die eu-sanktion
gegenüber diesen islamistischen Regime
im Menschenrechtsrat der Vereinten
Nationen in Genf hat unsere
Außenministerin erfolgreich eine
Resolution erwirkt die die Gewalt gegen
Demonstranten und Demonstranten im Iran
verurteilt und diese durch unabhängige
ohne Experte und Experten dokumentieren
sollen wir tun was in unserer
rechtlichen und politischen Macht steht
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren zum
Abschluss möchte ich noch einmal den
Blick weiten die mutigen Demonstranten
und Demonstranten im Iran sind Vorbild
für Frauen und Mädchen in der gesamten
Region in Syrien in Afghanistan gehen
die Frauen auf die Straßen das Video nur
kaum zu Kenntnis genommen als
Berichterstatterin für den Nano
Mittleren Osten für meine Fraktion die
selbst syrische Wurzeln hat möchte ich
danke sagen für diesen großen Mut danke
dass Frauen und Männer in der Region
danke dass Frauen und Männer eben in der
Region sich zusammen gegen das Unrecht
auflehnen und Freiheit fordern und dann
kann unsere Außenministerin Anna-Lena
Werbung die diesen Kampf politisch
mitführt es macht eben einen Unterschied
dass eine Frau als Chef Diplomatin den
Ton abgeben erst recht für diese
Regierung in diesem Sinne Frau Leben
Freiheit Gin
vielen Dank
von den Bündnis günstiger eine Art
politischen Hinterhalt der
Unionsfraktion die hat diesen Antrag ja
eingebracht iranische Protestbewegung
entschlossen unterstützen den Testfall
einer frauenorientierten Außenpolitik
zum Erfolg machen wie die Union das
Gemeinde das kann jetzt Johann David
wartepool von der cdu/csu-fraktion
vor dem Parlament
vor dem Parlament sagen werden zum
Beispiel jetzt gerade noch
weitere lösungsanalina behrburg zum 42
Geburtstag gratuliert jetzt wie gesagt
Johann David wartepool von der cdu/csu
Fraktion mit seiner Erklärung was hinter
den Antrag seiner Fraktion steckt den
herzlichen Glück und Segenswünschen für
unsere Außenministerin gerne anschließt
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
die Lage im Iran ist dramatisch die
Brutalität mit der das iranische Regime
gegen die breite Protestbewegung vorgeht
sucht seinesgleichen am 16 September
also vor fast drei Monaten ist die junge
Kurden Gina Amini durch brutales
Vorgehen der Sittenpolizei zu Tode
gekommen dies hat zu den größten
landesweiten Protesten gegen das
islamische Regime im Iran seit der
sogenannten islamischen Revolution im
Jahre 1979 geführt Proteste die im
ersten Moment
von vielen mutigen Frauen getragen
worden die gegen das repressive Regime
aufbegehrten ein Regime das seit
Jahrzehnten systematisch Frauen
unterdrückt und drangsaliert diesen
Protesten haben sich sukzessive immer
weitere Teile der Bevölkerung
angeschlossen Studenten Händler die
Mittelschicht ihre Forderung ist klar
ein grundlegender Wechsel im
herrschafts- und Gesellschaftssystem im
Iran anders als ihre Eltern Generationen
haben über 60 Prozent der iranischen
Bevölkerung die im Übrigen in etwa
gleich stark ist wie die deutsche die
unter 30 sind keine Beziehungen und
keine Bindungen zur islamischen Reform
sie wollen eine andere Staatsform dies
versucht das islamistische Terror-Regime
und Präsident reisi und die
revolutionsgarten zu unterdrücken die
Bilanz ist verheerend
schon jetzt wurden mehr als 18.000
Menschen verhaftet mehr als 400 Menschen
unschuldige Frauen Kinder wurden getötet
Berichte aus Gefängnissen sprechen von
schlimmsten Menschenrechtsverletzungen
Frauen werden vergewaltigt Kinder werden
gefoltert
die
ard-journalistin Natalie Amiri hat der
cdu/csu-fraktion geschildert dass sie am
Sonntag ein Beitrag senden wird wo eine
Minderjährige aus den Gefängnissen
berichtet und von den Schreien anderer
Mädchen erzählt die nach ihrer Mutter
rufen
wir sind im Mittelalter angekommen
es gibt öffentliche Hinrichtungen
dieses Regime hat offensichtlich nichts
mehr zu verlieren es wendet alle
barbarischen Methoden an und deswegen
sind wir alle aufgerufen ist die freie
Welt aufgerufen diesen Menschen diesen
Frauen diesen Kindern der Bevölkerung
des Iran insgesamt zur Seite zu stehen
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
aus Sicht der cdu/csu-fraktionen
reagiert die Bundesregierung darauf
jedoch wie üblich zu spät und sie macht
zu wenig sie sind entweder nicht bereit
oder nicht in der Lage das historische
Momentum und die notwendige Rolle
Deutschlands zu definieren und eine
darauf aufbauende konsistente
Außenpolitik zu formulieren erst am 26
September ganze 10 Tage nach der
Ermordung aminis hat sich die
bundesaußenministerin per Twitter
öffentlich zur Gewalt gegen
Demonstranten geäußert und meine lieben
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das haben die
Grünen uns ja gerade eben noch einmal
vorgehalten
feministische Außenpolitik verdient nur
dann
die Anwendung dieser Begriffe hier wenn
die Außenpolitik in ihren praktischen
Taten den eigenen Ansprüchen auch
gerecht wird und das ist nicht der Fall
das ist nicht der Fall
dazu kommt der Bundeskanzler
der Bundes der Bundeskanzler hat bis zum
26 September gebraucht bis er überhaupt
etwas dazu gesagt hat
gestern in der
Regierungserklärung vollkommen richtig
haben wir vom Bundeskanzler 20 Minuten
über internationale Politik gehört und
kein Satz zum Iran kein Wort keine Silbe
es ist Unfähigkeit ist es Unwille daher
deswegen muss ich noch mal darauf
hinweisen dass Mindeste was die
Inhaftierten die gefolterten von uns
erwarten können ist doch dass wir ihnen
eine Stimme verleihen und deswegen wäre
es die vornehmste Aufgabe des
Bundeskanzlers der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland gewesen hier an dieser
Stelle etwas dazu zu sagen und eine
klare Position für die unsere
Deutschland zu formulieren das ist nicht
geschehen und deswegen kann ich sie nur
auffordern dass Sie sich unseren Antrag
noch einmal anschauen und auch die
konkreten Forderungen sich anschauen was
dort drin steht es muss doch konkret
darum gehen dass Regime in Teheran
maximal unter Druck zu setzen ihren
handlungs- und
bewährungsbewegungsspielraum
größtmöglich einzuschrecken
einzuschränken wie kann es sein dass wir
dieser Tage zur Kenntnis nehmen dort
Deutschland immer noch der größte
Handelspartner des ihr Iran in der EU
ist glauben ich würde gerne fortfahren
in ihrem Antrag sprechen Sie davon das
müsste mal geprüft werden meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren in dieser
Zeit muss mehr gemacht werden als zu
prüfen sie müssen handeln die
Bundesregierung muss endlich etwas
praktisch tun
warum ist es Kanada möglich die
iranischen revolutionsgarten
komplett zu sanktionieren warum gibt es
in der Europäischen Union jetzt ein
erstes kleines sanktionspaketchen und
keine vollständige Sanktionierung der
Garden warum ist es immer noch möglich
dass die Kinder der revolutionsgarten in
Eliteschulen in Europa zur Schule gehen
und sich hier frei bewegen und diese
diese Schicht ein Leben in Saus und
ausführt hier muss mehr gemacht werden
hier muss Deutschland in eine
Führungsrolle gehen
warum
besteht das islamische Zentrum in
Hamburg immer noch als Drehscheibe der
Spionage und der auslandsrepression
dieses Regimes Bürgermeister Scholz sein
Nachfolger Tschentscher haben an der
Stelle nichts unter normalen sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren wir erwarten
von der Bundesregierung dass sie diese
Außenstelle
dreams hier schließt es muss endlich
etwas geschehen der Iran so wie er unter
diesem Regime agiert
außenpolitisch und in der Region steht
gegen alles was Deutschland wichtig ist
gegen Menschenrechte er stellt die
Existenz Israels in Frage er
verunsichert die gesamte Region
führt Militärschläge im Irak durch
destabilisiert den Libanon meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren dieses Regime
steht gegen alles was Deutschland
richtig ist und deswegen deutsche
Außenpolitik muss eine neue Iran-Politik
sein und muss sich endlich diesen Regime
widersetzen der Iran diese großen Kultur
Nation ist größer und dem müssen wir in
unserer Außenpolitik endlich gerecht
werden danke schön
dieser Antrag der Unionsfraktion ist vor
ca 8 Wochen schon einmal hier im Plenum
behandelt worden heute sind noch mal für
die Debatte 70 Minuten angesetzt danach
eine Abstimmung also bis etwa 12 Uhr
nächste Rednerin deriatürk Nachbauer von
der SPD sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
erst einmal herzlichen Glückwunsch zum
Geburtstag liebe Frau Ministerin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe Menschen
im Iran
wer wird der oder der wird die nächste
sein das ist die quälende Frage für
Millionen Iranerinnen und Iraner diese
in den Schlaf begleitet und morgens
schweißgebadet aufstrecken lässt
eine iranische Freundin erzählt mir dass
sie mit dem Handy in der Hand einschläft
und der erste Blick am Morgen Ihrem
Telefon gilt aus Sorge vor weiteren
schlimmen Nachrichten nach der
Hinrichtung der zwei jungen
Demonstranten
[Musik]
noch viel viel unerträglicher geworden
Marcel und man waren beide gerade erst
einmal erst 23 Jahre alt mOssen wurde am
Donnerstag in Tätern hingerichtet und
Malteser am Montag in Madrid sie hätten
einen Krieg gegen Gott und gegen die
islamische Ordnung geführt sagt die
Justiz ein Vorwurf der aktuellen
mindestens 38 weiteren Inhaftierten
Demonstranten das Leben kosten wird wenn
sich dieses terrorree nicht aufhalten
lässt wird es heute das Brüderpaar hat
und versati treffen oder den 19-Jährigen
Mohammed organi wie viele junge Frauen
wie ein Mieter Abi werden noch in den
Gefängnissen brutals vergewaltigt werden
um dann spurlos zu verschwinden noch wie
viele Mütter wie viele Väter wären ihre
Kinder zu Grabe tragen müssen und mit
dem Leichnam die ungelebten Hoffnung und
Träume ihrer Kinder beerdigen ich weiß
es nicht wir wissen es nicht was wir
allerdings wissen ist dass dieser
staatlich angeordnete Terror sofort
aufhören muss heute
heute willst du 90 Tage in diesen 90
Tagen wurden mehr als 18.000 Menschen
inhaftiert tausende vergewaltigt und
gefoltert über 460 getötet darunter über
60 Kinder die Demonstrierenden Menschen
im Iran zeigen uns das kostbarste Gut
ist die Freiheit es will mit Loyalität
und Mut verteidigt werden der Ruf nach
Freiheit lässt sich nicht einsperren die
Hoffnung auf Zukunft lässt sich nicht
vergewaltigen die Träume der Jugend
lassen sich nicht auspeitschen diese
Erkenntnis
diese Erkenntnis schüchtert die Führung
der Islamischen Republik Iran ein der
Mut dieser Protestierenden Frauen und
der Jugend auf den straßenversetzt
Carmen nee in Angst und Schrecken kann
man nie was ganz genau dass er alles
verlieren wird wenn diese mutigen
Menschen in Iran Straßen schon und
Universitäten nicht gestoppt werden die
Protestbewegung ist zu einer
Revolutionsbewegung geworden es gibt
kein zurück mehr das Ausmaß und die
Dauer des zivilen Aufstands gegen die
Mullahs und ihr Regime haben eine seit
Jahrzehnten nicht gesehen eine Wucht
erreicht das weiß die islamistische
Führung und daher ist jedes Mittel recht
diese willkürlich ausgesprochenen
Todesurteile sollen Stärke demonstrieren
sollen die Menschen einschüchtern diese
Exekution sind ein Signal der Schwäche
und der Angst an die Herren
Entscheidungsträger im Iran sie haben
Angst vor ihren eigenen Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern sie haben Angst vor
sie sind zwar besser ausgerüstet sie
haben das Geld sie haben die Strukturen
sie haben einen Überwachungsapparat sie
haben Partner die zu Ihnen passen aber
sie haben keine Zukunft die Zukunft
gehört der Freiheit
wir Demokratin
stehen dabei ganz fest an der Seite der
Unterdrückten Menschen das haben wir mit
dem von der Koalition eingebrachten und
beschlossenen Antrag vor wenigen Wochen
ziemlich deutlich zum Ausdruck gebracht
ohne die Frauen im Iran zum Testfall
erklären zu müssen ich wiederhole mich
weil ich das schon in der ersten Debatte
zu diesem Antrag gesagt habe die Frauen
im Iran sind weder ein Testfall noch ein
Spielball irgendwelcher Parteipolitik
liebe Kollegen von der Union das wissen
sie auch vielen was sie bereiten fordern
ist bereits Beschlusslage und vieles
anderes in Arbeit auch ich möchte die
revolutionsgarten geschlossen auf dieser
Terrorliste sehen ich ich möchte auch
die Abgeordneten des iranischen
Parlaments die für diese unmenschlichen
Hinrichtung plädieren auf genau dieser
Terrorliste sehen ich möchte auch die
Staatsanwälte und Richter die für diese
Exekution verantwortlich sind auf genau
dieser Terrorliste stehen es ist
einfach wie wir uns das wünschen dass
EU-Recht ist doch ziemlich klar
grundlage ist die kaum zu Nummer sage
ich ihnen nicht aber es ist dokumentiert
erste Voraussetzung ist dass eine
nationale strafverfolgungs- oder
Ermittlungsbehörde in einen
EU-Mitgliedstaat ein Verfahren
eingeleitet hat oder eine Verurteilung
erfolgt ist das ist bislang nicht der
Fall aber das wissen sie doch auch wir
tun alles was momentan rechtlich möglich
ist und da hat sich zum Glück schon
einiges getan auf Antrag Deutschlands
hat sich der Menschenrechtsrat der
Vereinten Nation Ende November mit der
Lage in Iran befasst
und für diese unabhängigen Untersuchung
der anhaltenden Gewalt gegen
demonstrierende gestimmt der Iran ist
gestern erst auf Betreiben der USA aus
einem UN-Gremium für Frauenrechte
ausgeschlossen worden das sind so
wichtige Zeichen bislang sind über 50
Einzelpersonen mit Revolution oder mit
Bezug auf revolutionsgarten gelistet
entweder im Rahmen des spezifischen Iran
sanktionsregimes oder im Rahmen des
menschenrechtssanktionsrechts die Liste
wäre lang es sind Banken sanktioniert es
sind Geldgeber sanktioniert es ist das
halbe abwehrkommenden Kommando
sanktioniert
die Listung weiterer Person das ist
alles in Arbeit die Menschen im Iran
brauchen die Geschlossenheit aller
Demokratien im Bundestag das bleibt
dieser Menschen eignet sich überhaupt
nicht dazu
parteipolische profilaktion hier
profilierungsaktionen hier zu starten
die Menschen im Iran die Menschen im
Iran und auch die iranische Community
bei uns hier in Deutschland brauchen
unser aller Stimme unseren Schutz und
unsere Unterstützung und vor allem eine
ehrliche und sachliche Erklärung des
EU-Rechts mit Parteipolitik ist in
dieser Situation wirklich niemanden
geholfen mit einigen iranischen Freunden
habe ich ausgemacht dass wir spätestens
an der Brust am Brandenburger Tor das
Ende dieses Müller Regimes tanzend
feiern ich hoffe Sie sind dann auch
dabei vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
soweit der Ria Türk Nachbau von der SPD
zur Iran Debatte im Bundestag nächster
Redner jetzt von der afd-fraktion Eugen
Schmidt er ist stellvertretendes
Mitglied des Auswärtigen Ausschusses
das
eint Fall zu sein
schriftführerinnen und Schriftführer mit
der Auszählung zu Beginn das Ergebnis
wird später bekannt gegeben
meinte damit die laufenden namentliche
Abstimmung zur
gaspreisbremse die ist jetzt beendet das
Ergebnis wird gleich bekannt gegeben und
wie gesagt jetzt Eugen Schmidt von der
afd-fraktion
Liebe Lars Leute
ein sehr großer Teil der iranischen
Bevölkerung ist unzufrieden mit der
politischen und gesellschaftlichen
Ordnung im Land die mutigen
Demonstrationen viele Iraner gegen
Kopftuchzwang und für Freiheit sind
unbedingt anerkennenswert die AFD sagt
die vormundung und Islamismus nein
Freiheit ja auch hier und vor allem in
Deutschland denn die vor wir uns mit
anderen Ländern befassen sollten wir die
Probleme im eigenen Land angehen es gibt
ein massives islamismusproblem in
Deutschland das ist offensichtlich aber
die Bundesregierung versteht hier vor
die Augen das ist das eine das andere
ist über die innere Ordnung muss ihm
jeweiligen Land selbst entschieden
werden Deutschland sollte hierfür auch
Dialog setzen und seine Unterstützung
anbieten die Bundesregierung muss mit
der iranischen Führung ins Gespräch
kommen und Spannungen abzubauen
Deutschland sollte Krisen entschärfen
und nicht anfeuern Gewalt darf kein
Mittel sein egal von welcher Seite
hunderte Tote Demonstranten aber auch
rund 60 getötete Sicherheitskräfte das
darf sich keinesfalls wiederholen wir
können uns keinen weiteren Bürgerkrieg
im nahosten erlauben wir wollen
Gespräche so wollen mit Führung als auch
Oppositionskräften falls vom iranischen
Volk gewollt ist könnte Deutschland als
Vermieter eine wichtige Rolle übernehmen
doch
Außenministerin hat das traditionell
vertrauensvolle deutsche iranische
Verhältnis schwer beschädigt sie setzt
sich stattdessen dafür ein dass deutsche
Waffen an Saudi Arabien geliefert werden
hierdurch wird der blutige Krieg
weltweit der im Jemen ist weiter
befeuert
Heuchelei und Selbstgefälligkeit Marken
grüne Außenpolitik
und die Union Sie meine Damen und Herren
von der Union lernen in ihrem Antrag
diplomatische Mittel der Handlungen
Gespräche ausdrücklich ab
stattdessen wollen sie Druck ausüben sie
schreiben weiter in ihrem Antrag die
konkrete Verbesserung der Lage der
Frauen im Iran muss Gradmesser für den
Erfolg der deutschen und europäischen
frauenorientierten Außenpolitik sein das
bedeutet der Erfolg deutsche
Außenpolitik mit sich daran inwiefern
sie die innere Situation eines anderen
Landes beeinflusst die Außenpolitik der
Werbung noch nicht grün genug das ist
oberflächlich arrogant lächerlich und
Besorgnisse regeln wollen sie die Grünen
überholen
die Politik der Union und der
Regierungsfraktionen Sicht auf
regime-wechsel ab dabei hat diese
Politik in den vergangenen 20 Jahren
unzählige Menschenleben gekostet ganze
Länder wurden verwüstet Afghanistan Irak
Liebe in Syrien
migrationsstürme wurden ausgelost und
Terence befeuert die Ehre und Gewalt
gelangten auch in unser Land doch diese
Bundesregierung und auch die Union wie
die Krisen nicht entschärfen im
Gegenteil sie haben eine Neigung zu
gewaltsamen Losungen sie haben nichts
auf den letzten 20 Jahren misslungene
westliche intuitionspolitik gelernt
hierzu kann AFD nur nein sagen wir sind
ja Alternative für Freiheit gegen
Gängelung für die Diplomatie und gegen
Gewalt und vor allem und stets am erster
Stelle für Deutschland
AFD die Friedenspartei
ja Eugen Schmidt von der AFD mit
zumindestens teilweisen Verständnis für
das Regime in Teheran erstaunlich für
eine Fraktion die sonst immer auf die
Gefahren die durch Islam und Islamismus
in Deutschland
entstehen können hinweist nächster
Redner ist Rainer sind von der FDP viele
Menschen hier in Berlin versammelt um
ein Zeichen der Solidarität mit den
Frauen und Männern im Iran zu setzen
Frau Leben Freiheit stand leuchtend in
mehreren Sprachen am Brandenburger Tor
wir stehen unter dem Eindruck der
grausamen öffentlichen Hinrichtungen der
hohen Gewalt auf den Straßen der
Verschleppungen mit denen das
mularregime verzweifelt versucht die
Bevölkerung von ihrem Freiheitskampf
abzuhalten unsere Mitgefühl gilt in
Angehörigen und Freunden der Getöteten
sie trauen um ihre Heldinnen und Helden
für unsere Maßnahmen die
Freiheitsbewegung zu unterstützen und
das Regime zu schwächen heißt das jetzt
erst recht
wir begrüßen als Freie Demokraten ganz
ausdrücklich die neuen Sanktionen die da
Außenministerrat Anfang der Woche in
Brüssel beschlossen hat sie enthalten
Einreiseverbote in die EU und Konto
Sperrungen mit den Sanktionen treffen
wir auch Kommandeure die die Befehle zu
den grausamen Taten gegeben haben zum
Beispiel beispielsweise einen Kopf der
iranischen Ordnungskräfte in der Provinz
sistan und belucistan er ist
verantwortlich für mehrere Massaker bei
denen protestieren der erschossen wurden
unter anderem in zachedan am 30
September und in Kasch am 4 November
diese Listen werden fortgeschrieben und
laufend ergänzt die Bundesregierung wird
alle Möglichkeiten ausschöpfen um die
Täter zu Verantwortung zu ziehen und die
Profiteure des Regimes mit den
Sanktionen zu treffen
unseren Kindern bringen wir bei wer
anderen Menschen absichtlich schadet
wird dafür bestraft und wir bringen auch
bei Verantwortung für Handeln zu
übernehmen
meine Damen und Herren wir wollen auf
internationaler Ebene werden wie
Verantwortung und Freiheit der
persönlichen Lebensgestaltung Ausdruck
verleihen und diejenigen unterstützen
die diese Rechte für sich einfordern und
es gibt keinerlei Legitimation jemanden
diese Rechte zu verweigern
ich freue mich dass maßgeblich die
deutsche Bundesregierung dafür
verantwortlich ist dass der
Menschenrechtsrat der Vereinten Nationen
auf seiner Sondersitzung vor drei Wochen
beschlossen hat eine unabhängige
Untersuchungskommission einzurichten
diese Kommission wird
Menschenrechtsverletzungen im Iran
identifizieren Beweismittel sammeln und
alle staatlichen und überstaatlichen
Instanzen in die Aufarbeitung einbinden
ja es ist politisch ein erster Erfolg
wenn Rechtssprüche verurteilt und damit
Druck auf die Verantwortlichen ausgeübt
wird aber machen wir uns bitte nichts
vor
Mehrheitsentscheidungen zugunsten von
Freiheit Demokratie und Menschenrechten
sind internationalen Gremien alles
andere als ein Selbstläufer
dem un- Menschenrechtsrat gehören 47
Mitgliedsstaaten an die Abstimmung zur
Einrichtung der Untersuchungskommission
viel mit 25 Jahre Stimmen
sechseinstellungen bei 16 Enthaltungen
aus das bedeutet 22 Mitglieder haben
sich also entschieden eine unabhängige
Untersuchung nicht zu befürworten fast
alles Länder in denen mehr oder weniger
abhängig die mehr oder weniger abhängig
von den großen Autokratien dieser Welt
sind um weltweit Freiheit und
Menschenrechte für Menschenrechte
eintreten zu können müssen wir den
systemwettbewerb ernst nehmen indem wir
uns mit China und Russland längst
befinden
der Uran wurde gestern aus der Menschen
frauenrechtskommission der Vereinten
Nation ausgeschlossen die sich für genau
diese Rechte einsetzt die die Mullahs
und ihre Handlanger so sehr fürchten das
ist das richtige Signal und ein
wichtiger weiterer Baustein der
Isolation der Staatsführung die
internationale Staatengemeinschaft zeigt
damit dass sie Gewalt und Unterdrückung
als regierungsmethode nicht belegt
und mit harten Konsequenzen versieht
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen geben wir
auch weiterhin der iranischen
Freiheitsbewegung all die Aufmerksamkeit
und Unterstützung die sie verdient und
benötigt danke schön
die von Rainer semeth erwähnte der von
Rainer semeth wenn der Ausschluss des
Iraners der UN-Kommission für die Rechte
der Frauen der wurde übrigens mit dem
Gegenstimmen von Russland und China
angenommen nächste Rednerin ist schon in
Wisla die Parteivorsitzende der Linken
am 16 September wurde
die Heike Masern getötet die
Sittenpolizei hatte sie wegen eines
angeblichen Verstoßes gegen die
islamischen Kleidungsvorschriften
festgenommen sie starb fünf Tage vor
ihrem 23 Geburtstag ihr Tod wurde zum
Vernal und zum Ausgangspunkt einer
landesweiten Protestbewegung im Iran
seit drei Monaten halten die
Massenproteste und Streiks gegen die
Unterdrückung durch das molaregime an
eine Revolution bei der
frauenvorreiterin sind ihr ruft nach
einem lebenden Würde und Freiheit hat
verschiedene Teile der iranischen
Gesellschaft vereint mit einem
dreitägigen Generalstreik in der
vergangene Woche erreicht die
Protestbewegung eine neue Dimension
Lkw-Fahrer Beschäftigte in Fabriken in
der Ölindustrie streikten was im Iran
gerade passiert ist historisch unsere
Solidarität gilt den Protestierenden wir
unterstützen ihren Kampf für einen
demokratischen und sozialen Iran und wir
haben Hochachtung vor der Mut und ihrer
Entschlossenheit
denn das Regime reagiert mit äußerster
Brutalität fast 500 demonstrierende
sollen getötet worden sein und fast
18.000 festgenommen darunter Kinder und
Jugendliche die Gefangenen berichten von
Folter und Vergewaltigung und besonders
gefährlich ist die Situation für die
Menschen in Kurdistan und belucistan die
seit Jahrzehnten drangsaliert und
marginalisiert werden die Regierung
versucht die Menschen mit Todesurteilen
und Hinrichtungen einzuschüchtern und
zum Aufgeben zu bewegen
moscenavat wurden in einigen
scheinprozessen zum Tode verurteilt und
hingerichtet beide waren 23 Jahre alt
ihr Verbrechen Teilnahme an Protesten
vielen anderen verhafteten droht
ebenfalls die Todesstrafe
es ist nicht das erste Mal dass das
Regime solche Methoden der Abschreckung
einsetzt um Widerstand zu unterdrücken
allein im Sommer 1988 wurden tausende
politische Gefangene in drei minütigen
Gerichtsverhandlungen zum Tode
verurteilt und in Massengräbern wir
Caravan bei Teheran verscharrt und der
heutige Präsident Rasi war schon damals
an den Morden beteiligt aber die
Menschen lassen sich nicht einschüchtern
sie protestieren weiter trotz alledem
und einige Abgeordnete die aus dem
Deutschen Bundestag haben ja politische
Patenschaften für zum Tode verurteilte
Menschen übernommen um Solidarität zu
zeigen mit den Verurteilten wir haben ja
gerade gehört es gibt eine Fraktion die
auf Seiten der Mutter steht das ist die
AFD das haben sehr deutlich gemacht ist
ja auch interessant zu hören
meine Damen und Herren der Bundeskanzler
darf nicht weiter schweigen die
Bundesregierung muss alle diplomatischen
Mittel einsetzen um den Druck auf das
Regime zu erhöhen und weitere
Hinrichtungen zu verhindern die
humanitäre Visa und passvergabe muss
erleichtert werden und natürlich muss es
einen dauerhaften Abschiebestopp in den
Iran geben nicht nur im Iran Leben
iranische Oppositionelle in Angst auch
in Deutschland werden Exil Iranerinnen
vom Regime bespitzelt eingeschüchtert
und drangsaliert erinnern wir an das
erinnern wir uns an das mykonosat 1992
bei dem iranisch kurdische
Oppositionelle in Berlin durch das
iranische Regime grausam ermordet wurden
das Wirken das iranischen Geheimdienst
in Deutschland das muss endlich
entschieden bekämpft werden meine Damen
und Herren
und die Bundesregierung muss Mittel
bereitstellen um
Menschenrechtsverletzungen zu
dokumentieren damit Täter auch zur
Verantwortung gezogen werden können
meine Damen und Herren die protestieren
im Iran schreiben Geschichte eine
Aktivistin sagt nein die Menschen wollen
keine Reform die eindeutig und zentrale
Forderung ist der Sturz der Islamischen
Republik es hat sich im Kern der
Gesellschaft grundlegend für etwas
verändert es ist ein Punkt erreicht an
dem es trotz der Repression kein Zurück
mehr gibt und ich will den
Protestierenden sagen die Welt schaut
auf euch die Welt schaut auf eure
Revolution nach Pablo Neruda sie können
alle Blumen abschneiden aber sie können
den Frühling nicht verhindern nie wieder
da waren
[Applaus]
nächster Redner ist Jürgen Trittin für
Bündnis 90 die Grünen ich hatte einen
Moment gezögert in der Annahme dass das
Abstimmungsergebnis über die
gaspreisbremse kommt das kommt noch
nicht jetzt Jürgen vor den Bündnisgrünen
der Iran ist im Nahen Osten etwas
Besonderes übrigens im Guten und das
liegt an den Menschen
die Mehrheit der Iranerinnen und Iraner
möchte ein strikte Trennung von Staat
und Religion sie wollen nicht mehr in
einem sogenannten Gottesstaat leben
und diese klare Haltung beruht auf den
Erfahrungen
mit einer islamischen Republik die sich
selbst als Gottesstaat definiert
doch was ist das für ein Gottesstaat
der seine Herrschaft auf den Strang
stützt welchen Gott ist das gefährlich
was ist das für ein Staat
der seit Jahren Minderjährige ermordet
der Rapper mit dem galgendroht
heute stehen 23 Menschen vor der
Vollstreckung der Todesstrafe unzählige
Verhaftung
tote Menschen die für Frauen Frieden
Freiheit auf die Straße gegangen sind
sie werden nicht nur mit dem Tode
bedroht sondern
die öffentlichen Hinrichtungen sollen
sie einschüchtern
diesen Menschen gilt unsere
uneingeschränkte Solidarität
Frauen Frieden Freiheit
das hat vor einigen Wochen
einen Fraktionsvorsitzenden hier
schenkelklopfen des Gelächter ausgelöst
nun legt die
cdu/csu eine
Antrag für eine frauenorientierte
Außenpolitik vor und da sieht man eine
Entwicklung
dann würde ich
lieber Kollege wadepool
auch in aller Freundlichkeit anmerken
dass sie genau wissen dass sie an dieser
Frage mit rhetorischen Fragen nicht
weiterkommen sie wissen sie wissen dass
es Voraussetzungen gibt
die für einen solche Listung
beispielsweise notwendig sind oder auch
für die Schließung eines iranischen
Zentrums was dieser Bundestag schon
lange fordert
aber sie hätten auch hinzufügen können
dass Deutschland das einzige Land ist in
dem nach den Schüssen auf die Essener
Synagoge nun mit den Ermittlungen des
generalbundes Anwalts ein solcher
Verfahren eingeleitet wird was die
voraussetzungslehre für die Listung der
revolutionsgarten als Terrororganisation
und das ist das woran diese
Außenministerin sehr hart arbeitet und
liebe Frau Wissler
ich teile viel von dem was Sie gesagt
haben aber wer es dann nicht einfacher
gewesen am 28.9 im Menschenrechtsrat mit
den anderen Fraktionen der Resolution
zum Iran zuzustimmen anstatt sich zu
enthalten
ich glaube bevor man mit
sondergeschichte andere der Untätigkeit
bezichtigt sollte man mal zur Kenntnis
nehmen das was im unmen
Menschenrechtsrat durchgesetzt worden
ist und Sie haben ja recht der Kollege
dass ich 16 enthalten haben aber wir
müssen mal feststellen dass sich Länder
wie Usbekistan und Kasachstan enthalten
haben die verkehrlich total von Iran
auch abhängig sind das ist schon ein
Erfolg dass sie nicht mit Nein gestimmt
haben und diese Erfolg geht zurück unter
anderem auf die Reise der
bundesaußenministerin in diese Länder wo
Sie aktiv an dieser Stelle genau für
diese Politik geworden hat und wenn
jemand wissen will was feministische
Außenpolitik ist dann ist das ein
Beispiel für feministische Außenpolitik
meine Damen und Herren
diese Ministerin die das dritte
Sanktionspaket vorangetrieben hat
übrigens nicht nur die Terroraktion
gegen die eigene Bevölkerung
sanktioniert sondern auch die
Unterstützung des Irans für den
drohnenkrieg Russlands in der Ukraine
das solche
bitte
seeministischen Außenpolitik und es ist
die Antwort auf ein Regime das sich auf
Gott beruft aber eine satanische Politik
betreibt
so weit irgendwie von den bündnisgründen
jetzt kommt Jürgen hart als nächster
Redner von Unionsfraktion er ist der
außenpolitische Sprecher seiner Fraktion
hier im Bundestag Jürgen hart
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir als
cdu/csu-fraktionen haben den iran-antrag
heute hier auch in der Kernzeit auf die
Tagesordnung gesetzt aus zwei Gründen
zum einen weil wir im Iran in diesen
Tagen und Wochen eine massive
Verschärfung der Brutalität des Regimes
gegen die zwiebelwirkung sehen in
Schauprozessen werden junge Menschen
abgeurteilt und hingerichtet das ist
etwas was uns zutiefst hohen rückt und
schockiert und zum anderen beunruhigt
und schockiert uns die nach wie vor aus
unserer Sicht zu zögerliche Haltung der
Bundesregierung in der Europäischen
Union wenn es um die Antwort auf diese
Taten geht und deswegen ist es gut dass
wir heute hier über diskutieren
jetzt sind in der Europäischen Union
wieder weitere zwei Dutzend alte graue
Männer die im Zweifel ihren Fuß sowieso
nicht für die Tür setzen hinterheran auf
die Sanktionsliste gesetzt worden
wir fordern als
cdu/csu-fraktion ein deutlich härteres
Sanktionsregime gegen den Iran
wir fordern dass die
revolutionären Garten als
Terrororganisation gelistet werden was
verschiedene Wirkungen hätte nämlich zum
ersten die Wirkung hätte dass junge
Menschen im Iran junge Männer im Iran
Wissen in dem Fall dass sie sich
anwerben lassen für diesen Teil des
staatsoperats sie einer
Terrororganisation angehören und dann
klick auf ihre Zukunft was Reisefreiheit
was studiermöglichkeiten was Geschäfte
angeht extrem eingeschränkt sind um zum
zweiten weil wir natürlich auch
diejenigen damit treffen die Geschäfte
machen mit diesen revolutionsgarten und
man muss ja wissen dass sie Meran ein
großer Teil der wirtschaftswirtschaft
ist und dass ein wesentlicher Teil der
Staatswirtschaft eben von diesem Garten
kontrolliert wird jetzt hat uns die
Bundesregierung und Herren hat das hier
übernommen gerade gesagt es gäbe
nationale und europäische rechts
Sachverhalte die uns daran hindern das
zu tun die Frage die ich dabei Stelle
ist wenn es nationale Gesetze gibt die
uns daran hindern diese führende
Terrororganisation in der Welt die ja
nicht nur das Volk im Iran unterdrückt
sondern die auch Kampf gegen Israel
führt die in Jemen die Terrorgruppen
unterstützt die in die Spoiler
unterstützt die im Syrien massiv wirkt
wenn es nicht gelingt aufgrund deutscher
Gesetze so etwas auch als
Terrororganisation einzuschätzen dann
möchte ich als Abgeordneter wissen
welche Gesetze müssen wir ändern um das
entsprechend tun zu können
das zweite es gibt eine eu-terrorliste
also erstens sind wir nicht einig mit
der Regierung das tatsächlich das
europäische Recht es untersagt diesen
Schritt jetzt zu gehen und zum zweiten
ständig auch da die Frage wenn das
europäische Recht nicht in der Lage ist
so etwas zu tun diese Listung als
Terrororganisation in diesem Fall dann
müssen wir überprüfen ob wir das
europäische Recht weiterentwickeln
müssen und da warte ich dann einen
Initiative der deutschen Regierung ein
zweiter
ein zweiter Punkt der mir sehr wichtig
ist und da kann ich nur an die Regierung
appellieren dass sehr ernst zu nehmen
wir erleben dass die Iran als mutmaßig
gegenwärtig der einzige Unterstützer
Russlands was konkrete
Rüstungsgüter angeht
massives Schäden anrichtet in der
Ukraine ukrainische Kindergärten werden
getroffen von Drohnen die die Russen
einsetzen weil sie sie vom Iran bekommen
haben
die Frage ist wie ist der Rhein in der
Lage solche Drohnen zu bauen und zu
exportieren da gibt es Presseberichte
das möglicherweise mikro-elektronik aus
Gütern die nicht einmal als duellius zu
betrachten sind zum Beispiel
Waschmaschinen möglicherweise Eingang in
diese iranischen Drohnen finden und das
damit letztlich auf diesem Umweg der ran
in der Lage versetzt wird diese Drohnen
zur Verfügung zu stellen ich kann die
Bundesregierung nur dringend auffordern
diesen Presseberichten aus der
finnischen Tanz zum Beispiel intensiv
nachzugehen denn es wäre ein großer
Schaden für Deutschland für das deutsche
ansehen und natürlich für das
ukrainische Volk sind tatsächlich
Bauteile aus Deutschland am Ende sich in
diesem Drohnen finden würden und wir
werden das im Ausschuss entsprechend
thematisieren
der dritte Punkt der mir wichtig ist zu
sagen die Bundesregierung
übt aus meiner Sicht zu große
Zurückhaltung gegenüber den regimeteran
vielleicht auch weil sie hofft doch noch
beim atomabkommen ccpoe zu einem
Ergebnis zu kommen um das hier klar zu
sagen ein solches Abkommen wollen wir
auch die Frage ob das ein realistischer
Weg eine Perspektive für die nächsten
Monate ist da mache ich ein großes
Fragezeichen ich sehe zum Beispiel nicht
Thema heute im amerikanischen Kongress
die die Wiederaufnahme eines solchen
Abkommens befördert was sich bei dieser
Regierung vermisse ist nicht dass man
das Engagement fortsetzt zu versuchen es
hinzukriegen sondern dass wir keinen
Plan B haben was wir eigentlich machen
mit der atombaren Bewaffnung des Iran
wenn es zu diesem Abkommen nicht kommt
auch über diese Frage müssen wir hier in
diesem Deutschen Bundestag müssen wir im
Auswärtigen Ausschuss intensiv
diskutieren und ich hoffe dass wir die
Gemeinsamkeit der Demokraten dieser
Frage beantragen herzlichen Dank
soweit Jürgen h von der Unionsfraktion
nächster Redner SKW Mansouri von der SPD
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Liebe zuschauende ich möchte
Ihnen von faserne und ihrem Ehemann
Hamid erzählen zwei politische Gefangene
im Iran für die ich die Patenschaft
übernommen habe ein Ehepaar bekannt für
sein Einsatz und seine Unterstützung in
Krisengebieten bei der medizinischen
Versorgung und Unterstützung von Kindern
am 3 November sind sie nach der
Trauerfeier für eine junge durch das
Regime ermordete Frau aus Sicht des
mularegims zur falschen Zeit am falschen
Ort in der Nacht wird das Ehepaar von
Sicherheitskräften zu Hause überfallen
vor den Augen ihrer Kinder schwer
misshandelt und verschleppt
im Gefängnis werden sie gefoltert und
erpresst falsche Geständnisse abzulegen
Hamid er leitet innere Blutungen und
rippenfrakturen
das schein Gerichtsverfahren gegen ihn
und seine Frau wird ohne rechtlichen
Beistand Ihrer Wahl durchgeführt faserne
wird eine Aussage verweigert Hamid wird
ohne Beweise und unter Missachtung
rechtsstaatlicher Mindeststandards zu
Tode verurteilt seine Frau faserne zu 25
Jahren Haft ohne Besuchsrecht das Ziel
ist liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen den
Anschein von Rechtsstaatlichkeit zu
waren und die Menschen zum Schweigen zu
bringen aber sie können nicht die ganze
Welt zum Schweigen bringt das hier ist
ein Haus der freien Rede liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der freiheitlich demokratischen
Bewegungen werfen die Mullahs Krieg
gegen Gott vor
doch die Menschen im Iran rebellieren
nicht gegen Gott
sie rebellieren gegen dieses Regime
dieses Regime verwechselt sich selbst
mit Gott
und sie brechen die elementarsten Regeln
menschliche Zivilisation Fritz Bauer
bezeichnete Zivilisation als eine sehr
dünne Decke die schnell abblättert
mit Schauprozessen Mord an Kindern
Massenhinrichtungen beweist das Regime
wie recht er hatte deswegen ist es auch
international isoliert und das ist auch
gut so
die Opfer der Revolution haben Gesichter
sie haben Geschichten und Botschaften
und diese lassen sich in einer freien
Welt nicht auslöschen viele in diesem
Parlament haben
Patenschaften für die über 18.000
politischen Gefangenen im Land
übernommen lassen Sie die Welt hören wer
die Menschen sind die von den Mullahs in
Folterkammern gesteckt werden es ist
wichtig dass wir laut sind für sie denn
die Menschen im Iran können uns hören
und sie sollen wissen es ist ihre
Revolution aber im Kampf für Freiheit
und Selbstbestimmung sind Sie nicht
allein wir stehen an ihrer Seite
mehrere EU sanktionspakete sind bei
mehrere EU sanktionspakete sind bereits
ein weiteres hinzugekommen unser
Parlament hat dem Regime vor Wochen
jegliche Legitimation abgesprochen im
un- Menschenrechtsrat ist auch dank der
Außenministerin eine Mehrheit gegen das
iranische Regime zustande gekommen und
will die Gewalt im Land unabhängig
untersuchen auch die aus der
UN-Kommission für Frauenrechte wurde das
Land nun ausgeschlossen es zeigt der
internationale Druck hilft und wichtig
ist dass wir mit dem Druck nicht
nachlassen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen mit einer Regierung die
Mordanschläge in Deutschland auch schon
hat durchführen lassen und offenbar
weitere plante werden wir nicht auf
Augenhöhe zusammenarbeiten die Spirale
der Gewalt braucht eine
unmissverständliche Antwort das ist
maximaler Druck gegen dieses Regime
und auch deswegen ist es wichtig
dass eine Terrororganisation wie die
Revolutionswächter auf eine Terrorliste
kommen und auch deswegen ist wichtig
dass sämtliche Abgeordnete die ihre Hand
für die Massenhinrichtungen gehoben
werden ebenfalls persönlich sanktioniert
werden liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und zugleich braucht es Unterstützung
für die Zivilbevölkerung die seit Jahren
unter den internationalen Sanktionen am
stärksten leidet keiner von uns weiß wie
lange
der Kampf bis zur Befreiung des Irans
dauern wird und weil das so ist dürfen
die Menschen im Land nicht auf sich
selbst gestellt sein freie Kommunikation
Austausch mit Kulturschaffenden Presse
Wissenschaft Versorgung mit Hilfsgütern
das ist wofür wir ein konkreten Beitrag
leisten können und auch leisten müssen
bei all dem wird auch entscheidend sein
dass dieses Parlament mit einer Stimme
in den zentralen Punkten spricht
im Iran fragt aktuell keiner
ob du Perser Kurde
Afghane Araber balucce oder
aserbaidschana bist da wird nur gefragt
bist du für ein freien Iran das ist eine
Frage die auch unser Parlament einen
sollte liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die Tage der Mullahs sind gezählt für
ihre Taten werden sie sich verantworten
aber das kann ein langer Weg werden
Menschen denen der Tod droht gehen auf
die Straße weil sie an den Sieg von
Freiheit Gerechtigkeit und
Selbstbestimmung glauben und wenn Sie
das tun dann sollten wir das auch setzen
wir auf den Erfolg der Revolution ich
danke Ihnen
soweit kW mansurde von der SPD mit
seinem Appell nächste Redner ist Jürgen
braun von der AFD
Sprecher für Menschenrechte und
humanitäre Hilfe seiner Fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren liebe Kollegen als das
islamistische Regime im Iran in den
letzten fünf Jahren
Demonstrationen brutal unterdrückt und
Internetsperren verhängt hat also es den
jungen Sportler Navid Askari verhaftet
und schließlich hingerichtet hat
da kam kein solcher Antrag von CDU CSU
im Gegenteil als die Union regierte half
sie dem islamistischen Iran sie stimmte
lauthals in das grünen linke Geschrei
gegen Donald Trump und seinen Ausstieg
aus dem atomabkommen ein dieses
sogenannte Abkommen ist dabei nur eine
politische Absichtserklärung gegen die
der Iran zu dem mehrfach verstoßen hat
es ist eine klassische Gutmenschen aus
Geburt der naiven ahnungslosen Obama
Regierung
die iranische Atombombe hätte diese
Absichtserklärung niemals verhindern
können beim besten Fall verzögern und
auch das nur im allerbesten Fall der
CDU-Außenpolitiker Norbert Röttgen
nannte das fragliche Abkommen der noch
ein außenpolitisches Glanzstück heute
spricht er nicht mehr davon den Ausstieg
der USA unter Trump geißelte als
Selbstisolierung und noch vor zwei
Jahren während der Sportler Navid afkari
in Haft gefoltert wurde bekräftigte
Röttgen es brauche den Anlauf für ein
neues Abkommen neue Gespräche mit den
Urlaubs nachdem das iranische
scheinparlament vor 5 Wochen beschlossen
hat dass allein die Teilnahme an den
Protesten als Krieg gegen aller
eingestuft wird ist der Weg frei für
massenhafte Exekution und die ersten
Todesurteile sind bereits vollstreckt
vor einer Woche haben die Müllers einen
23-jährigen gehängt am Montag folgte der
nächste junge Mann nur Tage zuvor waren
Todesurteile gegen 28
Demonstranten ergangen doch die mutigen
Proteste ging das islamistische
Gewaltregime gehen trotz aller Drogen
weiter seit drei Monaten
ebenfalls seit drei Monaten klagt
Außenministerin bärburg hier im Hohen
Hause und vor jeder sich bietenden
Kamera mal klagt sie wie schlecht es den
Menschen im Iran gehe mal klagt sie wie
schlecht es ihr selbst ihr angesichts
ihrer schweren Arbeit aber aus dem
Gesprächen zum atomabkommen ist sie noch
immer nicht ausgestiegen und die
islamische Revolutionsgarde hat sie noch
immer nicht als Terrororganisation
eingestuft
die AFD ist die einzige Fraktion im
Deutschen Bundestag die sich konsequent
gegen den politischen Islam stellt und
die sich schon seit Jahren seit vielen
Jahren für die Schließung des
islamischen Zentrums Hamburg einsetzt
sie haben das versäumt sie alle hier mit
uns gibt es keine Halbheiten wie bei der
Ampel und mit uns gibt es auch keine
plötzlichen unglaubwürdigen kehrtwänden
wie bei der Union vielen Dank
Jürgen braun von der AFD mit einem ganz
anderen Zungenschlag als sein
Fraktionskollege Eugen Schmidt vorhin zu
dieser Debatte zum Iran er hat ja
immerhin das Regime in Teheran als
Regime bezeichnet und er hat auch von
einem Terror erschien gesprochen nächste
Rednerin Renata alt von der FDP
Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der iranische Innenminister
Amad vahidi hat die Demonstrantinnen und
Demonstranten in Iran kürzlich als
Krawallmacher bezeichnet er will die
Ursachen der Proteste untersuchen lassen
ohne die Protestierenden jedoch zu
beteiligen das zeigt dass die mulat den
Kontakt zu der eigenen Bevölkerung
völlig verloren haben das molaregime ist
Reform unwillig es ist Reform unfähig es
ist gewalttätig und menschenverachtend
deswegen wollen die Iranerinnen und
Iraner das molare Schimmel beseitigen
die iranische Frauen und Männer
demonstrieren seit drei Monaten für die
Freiheit für die Demokratie und für
Menschenrechte dabei müssen wir sie
soweit wie möglich unterstützen
hunderte von Demonstranten wurden
bereits getötet darunter viele
Jugendliche und Kinder mehr als 18.000
Demonstranten wurden verhaftet diese
Woche wurden die ersten Gefangenen
gehängt ohne ein faires
Gerichtsverfahren viele Abgeordnete hier
im Hause übernehmen derzeit politische
Partnerschaften für inhaftierte im Iran
nicht nur hier aber auch in vielen
Landtagen in Deutschland dafür bin ich
ihnen sehr dankbar liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
wir fordern die Freilassung alle
politischen Gefangenen im Iran die EU
hat am Montag weitere Sanktionen
verhängt gegen 20 führende Vertreter des
Regimes und gegen den iranischen Sender
das ist gut reicht aber nicht liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Union
denn Druck auf das iranische Regime zu
erhöhen ist richtig aber in ihrem Antrag
fordern sie überwiegend das was wir als
Koalition bereits im November in unserem
Antrag vorgelegt haben und was gerade
Beschlusslage ist dem hätten Sie hier
gerne zustimmen können eine ihrer
Forderungen ist die revolutionsgabe als
terroristische Organisation einzustufen
einzustufen ja das fordern wir Freie
Demokraten auch aber bereits im April
2021 haben die USA die gesamte iranische
Revolution wir als terroristischer
Organisation eingestuft einer der Gründe
war dass zehn Agenten der
Revolutionsgarde an der Planung eines
Terroranschlags in Deutschland beteiligt
waren im Januar 2018 wurden sie vom
bundespreminaramt enttarnt ich frage
mich warum die damalige unionsgeführte
Bundesregierung daraus nicht sofort
dieser Konsequenzen gezogen hat wie die
Amerikaner
warum haben sie damals nicht gehandelt
heute kommt ihr der Forderung ziemlich
verspätet ihr Antrag ist zwar gut
gemeint beinhaltet aber wenig Neues in
diesem Sinne unterstützen wir Freie
Demokraten die Arbeit der
Bundesregierung Deutschland muss jedoch
schneller handeln damit nicht noch mehr
Gefangene hingerichtet werden ein
politischer Wandel und die lang ersehnte
Freiheit für alle im Iran müssen endlich
Wirklichkeit werden
weitere nata alt von der
FDP
maxlux von Bündnis 90 Sekunden ist der
nächste Redner in der Debatte iranische
Protestbewegung frauenorientierte
Außenpolitik ein Antrag der
unionsfraktionen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
demokratischen Fraktion seit über 90
Tagen heißt es ja im Iran jinjian Azadi
San zendigi also die zunächst stand
dieser Satz für Gerechtigkeit für Master
Gina armini und dafür steht er auch noch
nach wie vor aber inzwischen haben wir
doch alle erkannt und wir müssen es
aussprechen dieser Satz steht auch für
etwas weiteres er steht für den Sturz
des iranischen Regimes Gin Diana die
steht für eine Revolution im Iran
die Bewegung im Iran sie hat eine Stärke
historischen Ausmaßes angenommen diese
Stärke hat auch das brutale Regime
erkannt und es hat sehr hart
zurückgeschlagen 90 Tage des Protestes
für die Freiheit bedeuten auch 90 Tage
der Folter der Verschleppung der
splittergeschosse bedeuten zehntausende
inhaftierte mindestens 400 Tote darunter
auch Kinder bedeuten Berichte über
Vergewaltigung im Gefängnissen
Todesurteile von Menschen deren
Geschichten wir kennen aber auch eben
Geschichten wir nicht kennen und eines
trifft mich besonders hart viele der
jungen Menschen
denen eine Hinrichtung droht sie sind in
meinem Alter und ich möchte diesen
jungen Menschen sagen ihr habt genauso
sehr ein Recht auf Freiheit wie ich es
habe denn Freiheit ist nicht westlich
freiheit ist nicht östlich sondern
Freiheit ist universell und darum haben
wir die Pflicht an der Seite der
Freiheitsbewegung im Iran zu stehen und
wir dürfen nicht ruhen liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen bis nicht der letzte
politische Gefangene von Evi frei ist
meine Damen und Herren dieses Parlament
hier hat sich als erstes Parlament
Europas zu den Protesten im Iran Falten
mit der gemeinsamen Erklärung im
Ausschuss für Menschenrechte am 28.9 es
ist Deutschlands Außenministerin die
Sanktionen der EU durchsetzt die gegen
massive Widerstände eine eindeutige
Resolution im unmen Menschenrechtsrat
erreicht hat und dass wir aktiv sind und
dass wir laut bleiben das fordert auch
eine laute Zivilgesellschaft in unserem
Land und ich finde wir können dieser
Zivilgesellschaft dafür dankbar sein
denn sie zeigt Deutschland ist ein
menschenrechtsland
[Applaus]
und weil wir ein menschenrechtsland sind
werden wir nicht wegschauen die
Außenministerin ist weiter engagiert die
Koalition wird alle möglichen Maßnahmen
gegen dieses Regime ergreifen aber weil
wir ein menschenrechtsland sind wie das
auch auf rechtsstaatlichen und
geordneten Wegen erfolgen lassen sie uns
parteipolitische Spiele an die Seite
legen und lassen Sie uns gemeinsam alles
dafür tun dass wir an der Seite der
mutigen Freiheitsbewegung im Iran stehen
und lassen sie uns anders molare Regime
ein klares Signal aus diesen Parlament
senden die Tage dieses Regimes im Iran
sie sind gezählt danke schön liebe
Kolleginnen gemacht Max lux ist Obmann
seiner Fraktion der Bündnis Künstler
Fraktion im Ausschuss für Menschenrechte
und humanitäre Hilfe
voraussichtlich vorletzte Rednerin in
der laufenden Debatte die Bär von der
cdu/csu-fraktion dort stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen es wurde
heute schon mehrfach hier am Rednerpult
aber auch draußen in unserem Land aber
selbstverständlich auch im Iran der Ruf
vernommen cinchian assade Frau Leben
Freiheit ein Slogan der für eine
Revolution steht der seit Wochen deshalb
Monaten um die Welt geht und dass er
ausgerechnet vom Iran ausgeht grenzt an
ein Wunder da das Regime bisher alle
Proteste im Keim erstickt hat mit aller
Härte zurück schlägt wir haben es hat
auch schon von unterschiedlichen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen gehört dass der
Iran in all unseren Werten im Moment dem
entgegen steht wie Frauen dort vom
Regime systematisch unterdrückt werden
wo Frauenfeindlichkeit per Gesetz gelebt
wird wo die Frau nur halb so viel wert
ist wie der Mann und doch sind gerade
iranischen Frauen und natürlich auch
iranische Männer aber gerade auch von
den Frauen ausgehend eine ganz große
Revolution unterwegs wo leben riskiert
werden wo Mut zur Veränderung groß ist
weil eben die Wut die Verzweiflung der
in über 40 Jahren aufgestaute Zorn sich
in massiven Protest verwandelt hat und
wir haben uns in den letzten Wochen
gerade auch als
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion in jeder
Woche mit iranischen Frauen getroffen
mit AktivistInnen mit JournalistInnen
mit
Hausfrauen mit allen Frauen die hier in
unserem Land leben nicht nur auf
Demonstrationen in vier Augen Gesprächen
in sechs augengesprächen und haben uns
noch mal wirklich in letzter Zeit bei
einer täglich von den Gräueltaten
erzählen lassen die an der
Zivilbevölkerung verübt werden
wo inhaftierte ohne Anwalt oder der
Möglichkeit vermeintliche Beweise oder
die erhobene Anklage einzusehen eben zum
Tode verurteilt werden und dieses Urteil
auch unmittelbar vollstreckt wird und
trotzdem lassen sich die Protestierenden
nicht abschrecken in allen ethnischen
Gruppierungen in allen Schichten in
allen Landesteilen
geschlechterübergreifend
generationenübergreifen und besonders
daran ist auch dass die Frauen die sich
das Kopftuch in der Öffentlichkeit
herunterreißen auch oft frenetischen
Beifall von Männern ernten
ich finde es sehr schade und die
Kollegin Renate alt hat ja gerade
eigentlich sehr stark für unseren Antrag
gesprochen dass es heute an vielen
Stellen obwohl wir uns eigentlich in der
Bestandsaufnahme ja einig sind oder
einig sein müssten dass es von einigen
hier so parteipolitisch missbraucht
wurde an dieser Stelle und gerade gerade
von dem der am lautesten zwischenruft
früher hat man immer gesagt der
getroffen der Hund bellter Trittin
genauso ist es leider dass gerade sie
wirklich nur reden zur Parteipolitik
gehalten haben weil für uns natürlich
weil es auch die Kollegin lamiacador von
angesprochen hat dass wir in der Union
Begriffe wie feministische Außenpolitik
wie der wie der Teufel des Weihwasser
scheuen würden als erstes Mal hat mein
Kollege schon wurde wohl auch erwähnt
zweites Mal können wir auch
feministische Außenpolitik für
ministerische Außenpolitik für
ministerische Außenpolitik auch so oft
sagen wie sie hören wollen nur der Punkt
ist doch er muss wir Leben erfüllt
werden das ist doch das Entscheidende an
dieser Stelle Frau kador und für mich
ist die Situation der Frauen im Iran der
Lackmus-Test für diese feministische
Außenpolitik weil nur Worte reichen eben
nicht sondern es müssen dann eben auch
Taten folgen an dieser Stelle und ich
gehe noch weiter es geht nicht nur um
feministische Außenpolitik es geht um
wertegeleitete Außenpolitik für unser
Land weil selbstverständlich für uns die
Menschenrechte universell sind nicht
verhandelbar sind und gerade ist sie
beide haben das leider Gottes etwas zu
parteipolitisch machen gemacht hier und
deswegen hätte ich mich gefreut wenn von
den Grünen heute nicht die drei oder die
zwei Redner benannt wurden der Kollege
danach ging ja einigermaßen sondern wenn
auch die
Außenministerin wenn die auch
Kolleginnen Zwischenfrage nein wenn auch
die Außenministerin die das nicht zur
parteipolitisch gemacht hätte heute hier
gesprochen hätte wäre sicherlich der
Sache dienlich gewesen an dieser Stelle
ich würde mich freuen wenn wir einfach
genauso konsequent vorgehen wie uns
andere Länder des vormachen es wurde
vorhin erwähnt die Vereinten Nationen
haben den Iran wegen des brutalen
Vorgehens gegen die Protestbewegung im
Land aus der un-frauenrechtskommission
geworfen auch auf Antrag der USA die USA
und Kanada haben die Stärken der
revolutionskarte auf ihren Listen
terroristischer Organisationen und auch
wenn sie dauernd dazwischen rufen es
wusste schon Karton Senseo wir müssen es
einfach immer und immer wieder fordern
weil wir uns einfach Wünschen für die
Menschen im Iran für die Frauen für die
mutigen Männer das endlich auch diesen
Worten Taten folgen weil der Mut hier zu
stehen oder draußen vom Brandenburger
Tor zu Demonstrationen zu gehen ist doch
für uns alle total billiger Mut
natürlich machen wir das aber es ist in
unserem Land ganz wichtig dass eben dann
auch diese Taten kommen und ich finde es
schade dass außer dem Kollegen kW man
sorry von der SPD der einzige war der
Mann kon den Vorschlag von der Ampel
gemacht hat der einzige in dieser ganzen
Debatte vielen herzlichen Dank an sie
für ihre Rede dass da einfach zu wenig
kommt und zwar von allen drei Fraktionen
sie haben jetzt die Chance alle unseren
an unserem Antrag zuzustimmen der ein
sehr sehr guter Antrag ist und der
überall auch Gehör würde finden würden
aber ich kann auch alle noch mal
auffordern Netzwerke zu nutzen auch
unseren Schwestern und Brüdern im Iran
mit unseren reden mit unserem Handeln
aber auch eine Botschafter Hoffnung zu
schicken ich würde mich auch freuen wenn
viele noch auch Patenschaften übernehmen
und vor allem wäre es auch ganz wichtig
wenn wir noch über Weihnachten hinaus es
auch immer wieder aufrechterhalten
können weil sobald wir wegschauen
sterben Menschen wir wollen nicht
wegschauen deswegen auch dieser Antrag
auch in der Kernzeit heute bitte
unterstützen Sie unseren Antrag gegen
das Regime für die Menschen im Iran
vielen Dank
Luisa Amtsberg von den bündnisgünden
verzichtet offenbar auf eine
Kurzintervention nachdem sie keine
Zwischenfrage stellen konnte letzte
Redner
ich entschuldige mich beim Kollegen
Frank Schwabe dass er kurz noch warten
muss ich habe versucht Zwischenfragen zu
stellen bei allen Rednerinnen und
Rednern der Unionsfraktion sie ist doch
Luisa Arnsberg zugelassen deshalb jetzt
hier meine Intervention an dieser Stelle
sie kritisieren sehr viel vor allen
Dingen dass ihnen viele Reaktionen zu
spät kam dass es zu wenig ist und dass
es zu langsam ist und ich finde gute
Oppositionspolitik und da können sie
sich ja auch von uns was anhören weil da
haben wir Erfahrung mit ja lebt auch
davon dass man bestimmte politische
Handlungen eine gewisse
Verhältnismäßigkeit rückt und deshalb
möchte das an dieser Stelle einfach nur
mal sagen zu große Zurückhaltung wir
haben 2019 im Iran Proteste gehabt die
hunderten von Menschen das Leben
gekostet haben ich bin mir sehr sehr
sicher dass sie nicht weggeguckt haben
und es ignoriert haben ich bin mir sogar
sicher dass sie rausgegangen sind und
überlegt haben was können wir eigentlich
gegen das Regime im Iran machen was
können wir gegen die Revolution Garden
machen und trotzdem sind sie nicht
gelistet worden ja wir werden
wahrscheinlich heute an einer anderen
Situation aber ich unterstelle ihn mal
dass es Ignoranz war sondern dass sie
genau wissen wie kompliziert dieses
Verfahren ist und dass man es eben nicht
in der politischen Willensbekundung
einfach in die Welt pusten kann oder er
hat einfach Gesetze ändern kann die dazu
führen dass das einfach mal im
europäischen Kontext nicht mehr so
rechtsstaatlich geregelt wird es
brauchen braucht juristische Grundlagen
valide Grundlagen die am Ende auch zu
Erfolg führen denn das schlimmste was
passieren kann ist doch wenn so ein
Verfahren so ein Versuch schief geht das
würde doch kein Rechtsstaat der Welt
helfen und da
weitergeht wegen zu langsam Reaktionen
ja ich meine es ja nicht so dass das
nicht geprüft wird auch die Sanktion
werden immer wieder auf den Prüfstand
gestellt Sanktionen die auch sie
versucht haben nach 219 auf dem Weg zu
bringen die im Übrigen für ihre
Implementierung zwei Jahre gebraucht hat
Annalena baerbock hat mit täglicher
Präsenz in der Welt und auch
internationaler Ebene es geschafft das
erste Paket in vier Wochen auf dem Weg
zu bringen wir müssen mal über
Verhältnismäßigkeiten Reden an dieser
Stelle und die gesamte internationale
Gemeinschaft nach Genf zu holen und dort
noch einen großen Teil nicht nur hinter
sich zu bringen sondern eine Resolution
nicht nur eine Resolution sondern eine
starke Resolution auf den Weg zu bringen
das ist der Erfolg dieser
Bundesregierung und wir würden uns
wünschen dass sie aufhören würden auf
dem Rücken der vielen dann auch ernst zu
nehmen und wirklich auch
nachvollziehbaren Gefühle der
Iranerinnen und Iraner in der Diaspora
das zu instrumentalisieren die
feministische Außenpolitik zu über
politisieren denn auch in Afghanistan
gehen Frauen auf die Straße auch in der
ganzen
Politik groß geschrieben das müssen sie
auch hier an dieser Stelle mal zur
Kenntnis nehmen
Amtsberg die hier als Abgeordnete der
bündnisgrün gesprochen hat sie ist aber
auch gleichzeitig beauftragt der
Bundesregierung für Menschenrechtsfragen
und Dorothea wer mit dir mit der
Erwiderung
liebe Frau Kollegin Amtsberg zunächst
mal
jetzt müsste es funktionieren ich fange
nochmal an liebe Frau Kollegin Amtsberg
zunächst mal bedauere ich sehr dass
Ihnen von ihrer Fraktion keine Redezeit
gegeben wurde weil sie anscheinend jetzt
noch mal länger gesprochen haben als die
Redner vorher und ehrlicherweise bei den
vielen Minuten wo sie sehr viel geredet
haben und nichts gesagt haben sind
trotzdem zwei Dinge bemerkenswert
erstens mal in einer Situation wo jeden
Tag Menschen hingerichtet werden zu
sagen wir müssen über
Verhältnismäßigkeiten reden ist in
diskutabel unmöglich und das zweite zu
sagen wir waren schnell wenn es zehn
Tage Dröhnen des Schweigen gegeben hat
dann sag ich das war nicht schnell das
war zu langsam das wissen sie auch ihre
Kollegen hat vorhin dazwischen gerufen
das haben sie jetzt schon so oft gesagt
ja und wir werden es auch wieder und
wieder sagen weil wir nicht zulassen
dass wir länger abwarten auch als
Opposition weil wir unsere Arbeit ernst
nehmen wir hören jeden Tag von Frauen
die Sterben von Männern die Sterben von
Kindern denen ins Gesicht geschossen
wird und deswegen erwarten wir und es
können auch die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
erwarten dass diese Regierung schneller
handeln
das war noch ein Schlagabtausch zwischen
Luise Arnsberg und dorthin Bär jetzt
kommt er zum Zug Frank Schwabe von der
SPD Sprecher für Menschenrechte und
humanitäre Hilfe und der voraussichtlich
letzte Redner der laufenden Debatte
Frau Vorsitzende
verehrte Damen und Herren was ist das
für ein Regime dass die eigenen Kinder
umbringen lässt und ich meine das muss
man sich immer klar machen während wir
hier debattieren sitzen Menschen in
Zellen und wissen nicht ob Sie in Kürze
gehängt werden junge Menschen die nichts
anderes wollen als ihre Freiheit das ist
heute deutlich geworden in der Debatte
dass dieses Regime ich glaube dass die
Einigkeit einen großen Teil des dieses
Hauses längst jede Legitimation verloren
hat und auch wenn die Demonstrationen
nicht mehr so stattfinden können weil
sie dramatisch und drastisch unterbunden
werden wir sehen die Proteste wir sehen
das Geschäfte geschlossen sind wir sehen
das Künstlerinnen und Künstler sich
weigern weiterhin zensiert Filme zu
zeigen oder Bücher zu veröffentlichen so
herzzerreißend das alles ist am Ende
wird in der Tat die Veränderung nur aus
dem Land selbst kommen können aber wir
kennen helfen
wir können helfen indem wir den Protest
den es gibt sichtbar machen
indem wir aufklären indem wir den
Resonanzboden schaffen für Menschen die
protestieren weltweit im Iran in
europäischen Ländern und auch in
Deutschland das sind Frauen in
Deutschland beispielsweise wie Düsen
die hier diesen Protest bündeln in
Deutschland und wir können versuchen das
Ganze ins Parlament zu bringen wir
können versuchen das Brandenburger Tor
er strahlen zu lassen um genau diesen
Prozess deutlich zu machen Frau Leben
Freiheit in Diana die
oder
wir können es machen und das ist
vielfach gesagt worden indem wir
Patenschaften übernehmen und es machen
wir viele Patenschaften wir wollen
morgen ich will das mal sagen für alle
die die da noch sich beteiligen wollen
das auch demonstrieren indem wir uns vor
dem Parlament treffen und alle
diejenigen bitten die eine Patenschaft
übernommen haben dort morgen auch
entsprechend dabei zusammen sind wir
nicht alleine in Deutschland sondern es
sind viele europäische Länder sind in
Deutschland viele Länder Parlamente wo
entsprechend solche Patenschaften
übernommen werden weil das dass das was
wir machen können
sichtbar zu machen wer gerade vom Tode
bedroht ist und solidarisch mit den
Menschen zu erklären und wir können die
Debatte ins Parlament bringen und das
ist das wo ich sagen würde dass es das
Verdienst dann auch der Union weil sie
haben den Punkt haben sie auch gesagt
heute entsprechend aufgesetzt aber ich
will es dann vielleicht noch mal
versuchen Frau Bär weil sie versucht
haben das ja auch versöhnlich
zu machen wir können ja die Einigkeit
herstellen dass wir alle wollen dass die
revolutionsgarten verboten werden und
wir können aber doch auch die Einigkeit
herstellen indem wir deutlich machen
dass es diese Bundesregierung die
wirklich versucht alles zu tun um den
Iran
auch zu isolieren und entsprechend den
internationalen Protest zu organisieren
ich glaube der deutsche Botschafter im
Iran ist häufiger im iranischen
Außenministerium als in der Botschaft im
Iran das macht doch deutlich was
Deutschland da tut der auch wenn
Menschenrechtsrat und die Aktivitäten
dort sind entsprechend
beschrieben worden und deswegen bitte
lassen Sie uns das doch dann so machen
dass wir diesen propans nicht aufbauen
indem sie irgendwie sagen wann jemand
was getötet oder nicht das ist doch
absurd dieser Bundesregierung zu
unterstellen dass sie im Rahmen der
Menschenrechtspolitik nicht ausreichend
unterwegs ist und wenn diese Debatte
wirklich am Ende zu was dient über die
Frage des Iran hinaus dann ist es in der
Tat und es begrüße ich ja dass sie sich
öffnen für die Begrifflichkeit der
feministischen Außenpolitik vielleicht
am Ende dann auch noch mal in der in der
richtigen Begrifflichkeit man kann das
alles nachlesen bei Margot valströmen
die waren nämlich diejenige die das
ganze mal entwickelt hat als eine
Außenpolitik die nicht nur auf Frauen
auch auf Frauen aber nicht nur auf
Frauen guckt sondern den Menschen die
marginalisiert sind bisher in
außergewärtiger Politik eine neue Stimme
verleiht das sind zum Beispiel auch
indigene und viele andere mehr und wenn
wir jetzt uns darauf einlegen dass wir
diesen Begriff auch benutzen weil er ein
fortschrittlicher Begriff ist weil er
dazu führt Außenpolitik anders zu
betrachten und anders zu diskutieren
dann ist diese Debatte zumindest schon
mal für etwas gut verehrte
protestierende
im Iran wir hören euch das ist glaube
ich die Botschaft die auch von dieser
Debatte heute noch ausgeht und wir
müssen alles tun damit diese Proteste
weiterhin gehört werden können auch von
genjinigen die in Europa die in
Deutschland unterwegs sind und mich
besorgt sehr die Berichte darüber dass
Menschen in Deutschland bedroht werden
Iranerinnen und Iraner aus den Exil aber
auch andere die sich hier organisieren
die hier organisierten Protest auch auf
die Straße bringen in die sozialen
Medien bringen werden bedroht und ich
glaube das ist ganz wichtig dass auch
das Signal ausgeht die deutschen
Sicherheitsbehörden gucken ganz genau
hin wir werden uns ganz genau angucken
dass diese Menschen frei in Deutschland
agieren und protestieren können
ich könnte zum Ende dieser Debatte
nutzende und hunderte Namen nennen ich
bin Layla Hussein Sade nennen das ist
nämlich diejenige für die ich eine
Patenschaft übernommen habe leider ist
studentische Aktivistin sie ist vielfach
inhaftiert gewesen in den letzten Jahren
und sie hat eine schwerwiegende
Autoimmunerkrankung deswegen ist die
eigentlich haftunfähig sie sitzt aber
seit dem August wieder im Haff in Haft
im Iran und sie hat erst in den letzten
Tagen es geschafft eine audiobo
Botschaft nach außen außen senden zu
können die deutlich macht wie schwer
krank sie ist und wie bedroht sie
entsprechend ist deswegen ist unsere
Forderung auch hier von heute aus dem
Deutschen Bundestag von diesem Redner
abholt lassen sie leider Jose sadi und
all die anderen die nichts anderes tun
als für die Freiheit einzustehen frei
dieser Bundestag verneigt sich vor den
Protestierenden denjenigen die jetzt für
Freiheit
und leben ihr Leben aufs Spiel setzen
Frau Leben Freiheit jinjan Azadi
ich schließe die Aussprache wir kommen
zur Beschlussempfehlung des Auswärtigen
Ausschusses zu dem Antrag der Fraktion
der cdu/csu mit dem Titel iranische
Protestbewegungen entschlossen
Unterstützung ins unterstützen den
Testfall einer frauenorientierten
Außenpolitik zum Erfolg machen der
Ausschuss empfiehlt in seiner
Beschlussempfehlung auch Drucksache 47
75 den Antrag der Fraktion der cdu/csu
auf Drucksache 39 30 abzulehnen wer
stimmt für diese Beschlussempfehlung
das ist DIE LINKE SPD Bündnis 90 die
Grünen FDP und die AFD wer stimmt
dagegen dass es die cdu/csu Enthaltung
keine dann ist die Beschlussempfehlung
angenommen
damit würde der Antrag der
Unionsfraktion iranische Protestbewegung
entschlossen unterstützen der Testfall
einer frauenorientierten Außenpolitik
zum Erfolg zu machen abgelehnt